[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález en colombia
la muerte del ciudadano javier ordóñez a
manos de la policía local de ese país
generó una ola de manifestaciones
ciudadanas que se extendieron a lo largo
de varios días y que terminaron con
violentos enfrentamientos entre la
policía de ese país y los manifestantes
veamos algunos datos
esta jornada de violencia ha dejado
hasta el momento 14 personas fallecidas
100 personas heridas y más de 70 calles
o centros de atención inmediata
destruidos 9 buses también fueron
incinerados y varios establecimientos
fueron saqueados 119 casos de abuso
policial han sido denunciados hasta el
momento por la alcaldía de la ciudad de
bogotá la capital de colombia
este llamado estallido social pone en la
mesa una posible reforma a la policía
colombiana que es impulsada por la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez una
propuesta que fue rechazada por el
presidente del país iván duque quien
generó también polémica después de
aparecer llevando parte del uniforme de
la policía nacional en señal de respaldo
a esta institución y no mostró empatía o
cercanía con las víctimas y sus
familiares veamos otros datos
la policía nacional de colombia tiene
unos 160 mil efectivos activos y a
diferencia de muchos países tiene un
carácter militar no es una policía civil
y de ahí que funcione bajo lógicas
militares depende del ministerio de
defensa de ese país ha sido fuertemente
usada en la lucha contra las guerrillas
a lo largo de la guerra civil que vive
ese país entre 2016 y 2017 que son
algunas de las cifras más recientes hubo
cerca de 13.000 quejas en su contra por
abuso físico que para una buena parte de
los colombianos estos casos quedan en la
impunidad además de ser señalada o
percibida por algunos de los colombianos
como una institución corrupta que abusa
de su poder y no cumple a cabalidad su
labor
pero más allá del descontento coyuntural
que hay por la policía en colombia este
país tiene un escenario muy complejo
porque hay indignación por el
recrudecimiento de la violencia en
algunas zonas del país que por décadas
habían sido afectadas por el conflicto
armado también se han incrementado en
las últimas semanas las masacres contra
civiles el proceso de paz avanza a una
velocidad mínima y la población reclama
seguridad presencia del estado y sobre
todo liderazgo político el panorama
general de colombia en medio de esta
crisis sanitaria desatada por la
pandemia del cobi 19 no es muy alentador
por eso vamos a analizar este tema ya
hemos invitado a margarita restrepo
ellas representante a la cámara por el
partido centro democrático también está
con nosotros marianela garzón ex esposa
de javier ordóñez una de las víctimas de
estos enfrentamientos tan recientes en
la ciudad de bogotá y leona valencia
agudelo él es director y fundador de la
fundación paz y reconciliación
también queremos conocer sus opiniones y
sus preguntas en torno a este tema
pueden unirse al debate a través de las
redes sociales france24 yo en el piso
sant y luego dejé todo con la etiqueta
numeral el debate efe 24 comienzo
preguntándole entonces a margarida a
nuestra primera invitada la primera
persona que presentaba si son necesarias
unas posibles reformas a la policía
colombiana después de los hechos
recientes y de la tensión que hay entre
presidencia y la alcaldía de bogotá la
atención que hay entre los ciudadanos y
la institución de la policía y el
gobierno nacional
la margarita me oye
margarita bueno vamos a restablecer más
adelante entonces la conexión con
margarita habla entonces con my angélica
quien es esposa de una de las víctimas
que en estas últimas semanas falleció en
estos enfrentamientos fue justamente
javier ordóñez la persona que falleció a
manos de la policía y que ha desatado
toda esta serie de protestas de
indignación que se suma a muchos otros
temas marc y angélica
lamento mucho la pérdida que usted tuvo
en estas semanas lamentó la situación en
la que usted se encuentra que le ha
dicho el gobierno nacional a usted de su
familia
bueno muy buenas noches
pues el gobierno nacional
sacó un comunicado lamentando mucho la
pérdida y lo que había sucedido
sin embargo por parte de
ellos no tenemos ningún tipo de
acercamiento a la familia no hemos
tenido tampoco pues algún acompañamiento
ha sido claro para nosotros que en este
momento y con esta pérdida y con todo lo
que pasó estamos tenemos que seguir
adelante tenemos que buscar la justicia
claramente por nuestro por nuestra
propia parte no porque no ha sido clara
no ha sido evidente la ayuda o el apoyo
no ninguna ayuda sino el apoyo del
gobierno nacional en este momento sí
león valencia cuál es su impresión en
torno a estas protestas recientes porque
son múltiples los factores que están
generando este tipo de manifestaciones
pero los hechos recientes
tienen poco precedente en este país han
sido unas protestas muy violentas y
sobre todo porque ha dejado muchas
víctimas civiles
pues es la indignación ciudadana ante
hechos horrorosos cometidos por una
fuerza del estado por la policía
nacional es una iniciativa de nación
justa y en esa indignación participan
muchos los jóvenes y son jóvenes que han
sido agredidos antes seguramente en los
caic y seguramente por la policía muchos
de esos jóvenes son no es tan niño
empleados ni están estudiando son
jóvenes desesperanzados que muchas veces
son capturados en las calles y al
preguntarle dónde trabajan lo pueden
decir y si a preguntarle a donde
estudian no pueden decir porque no
tienen esa condición y claro no pueden
tener el alumno por voluntad de ellos
sino porque no hay alternativas para la
juventud y lo que reciben después los
llevan a los calle para indagarlos y
luego reciben golpes de la policía como
usted bien describió en esta primera
parte
donde hizo un diagnóstico muy exacto de
lo que ocurre en colombia de manera que
la indignación es justa y lo más grave
es que para ocultar que existe esa
indignación y que existe ese atropello
tan brutal de la fuerza pública
sobre los manifestantes el gobierno se
inventa el cuento de que lo que hay
detrás son organizaciones terroristas
organizando este tipo de manifestaciones
pues no no es posible porque la
manifestación ciudadana resulta horas
después de que hay esa muerte de ordóñez
que es una muerte que la conocemos por
un vídeo donde el horror es
impresionante porque no solo está
muriendo la persona atropellada sino que
le están diciendo a esa policía no lo
haga mire o ya lo estamos grabando no lo
haga pero saben que hay tal impunidad
que pueden hacerlo y entonces lo hacen y
hay tal impunidad que los dos policías
involucrados
hoy no aparecen por ningún lado la
policía los protegió y luego los se les
permitió que se fugaran que y ahora
estamos que no hay ni los responsables
de esa muerte pero tampoco y mucho menos
los responsables de las otras muertes
que ocurrieron en las protestas que
seguían de manera que la cosa es muy
grave en el país y necesitamos una
vigilancia internacional sobre ellos que
estarán haciendo el estado a trump de
ellos transmitiendo listado recojo
recojo tres palabras de su intervención
leon indignación atropello impunidad
margarita creo que ya tenemos la
conexión con usted
creo que ya ahora sí me oye creo que
puedo escuchar claramente lo que está
diciendo nuestros dos invitados en
margarita sus impresiones sobre este
tema y sobre esto que dice león
indignación atropello impunidad y lo que
decía maría angélica prácticamente no
hay respaldo por parte del estado
por el primero que quiero solidarizarme
con las víctimas y rechazar
contundentemente los hechos que han
acontecido en colombia de
aproximadamente del 9 de septiembre
hasta el día de hoy
estas imágenes que hemos visto son
devastadoras generan mucha controversia
pero lo más importante es que estas
imágenes no pueden generar más violencia
no pueden los colombianos seguir
permitiendo que los alaris y los
manipulen personajes siniestros con
intenciones específicas yo quiero
aclarar varias cosas lo primero es que
la policía colombiana es una policía
civil con la autorización de porte de
armas pero es una policía civil que
depende el ministerio de defensa pero es
una policía civil lo segundo es que los
jóvenes que marchan no son protestas
pacíficas lo que está ocurriendo en
colombia lo que está ocurriendo en
colombia son
turbas de personas que salen a protestar
incitados por personajes siniestros
las turbas los jóvenes desconocen los
protocolos de las marchas pacíficas
por eso son manipulados y los policías
se han excedido en la fuerza no se puede
juzgar a una institución a la policía
nacional por dos personas que hayan
cometido errores yo frente a las cifras
a las que tú te referías el principio
quisiera adicionar algunos por ejemplo
desde el 2000 no desde el septiembre 9
al 2015 ha habido 309 actividades en
torno a estas protestas manipuladas
incluso por personas que pertenecen a la
política e incluso no es que es la
policía o que inteligencia en colombia
tenga que inventar nada hay vídeos
incluso de estos líderes que con total
desfachatez salen a incitar a la
violencia
su segundo hay 319 policías lesionados
hay 11 particulares muertos hay 141
particulares lesionados hay 95
instalaciones de policías afectadas 79
está acá y tal como tú lo decías 164
vehículo
y 371 capturas por parte de la policía
además hay 54
investigaciones disciplinarias a los
policías y hay dos investigaciones en
caso de muerte los policías están siendo
investigados que acaban de ser pasados a
la justicia ordinaria entonces no es
verdad que esté el estado cruzado de
brazos frente a la impunidad se ha
mandado un mensaje de impunidad al
pueblo colombiano muy negativo que yo
pienso que esto también alienta a esta
cantidad de gente a salir porque sabe
que no va a haber ningún tipo de sanción
porque en colombia con el proceso de paz
si es verdad marcha muy lento lashkar no
han cumplido no han devuelto los niños
no han entregado las armas no han
indemnizado a una sola víctima pero
además se mandó un mensaje que delinquir
si paga suerte al contrario el gobierno
si la ha cumplido a los terroristas de
las farc y hoy por hoy tienen curules
tienen 13 emisoras tienen
han colocado una cantidad de personas al
empleado una cantidad de personas
entonces los jóvenes en las calles claro
que están lados están indignados con la
impunidad y con la injusticia porque
jóvenes que deberían estar trabajando no
es tu trabajo pero los terroristas de
las farc si tienen trabajo remunerado
por el estado maría angélica su esposo
javier ordóñez abogado fue una de las
primeras víctimas de estas semanas o
estos días de furia que vivió la ciudad
de bogotá
qué opina usted de lo que hizo margarita
son turbas
son personas que están influenciadas que
hay una mano oscura por detrás que
influencia estas manifestaciones y que
no son del todo pacíficas cuál es su
opinión al respecto sabiendo que su
esposo estaba en una de ellas
mira no yo te voy a hacer claridad y
precisión en algunas cosas
javier era mi ex esposo segundo
claramente él no estaba involucrado en
ninguna de estas turbas porque
lo que le ocurrió a él fue un hecho
digámoslo en un momento diferente o sea
él es la primera víctima que ocurre que
pues que padece el abuso de los policías
la noche del 9 ese entre la noche del 8
y 9 y amanecer el 9 de septiembre
es el vídeo que sale donde pues se ve
claramente todo lo que hacen con él
hasta llevarlo a la moción
y yo pienso y voy a dar mi punto de
vista respecto a lo que está sucediendo
yo pienso que el estado no ha
comprendido la magnitud de lo que está
pasando el gobierno nacional no lo ha
comprendido creo que cuando pasan este
tipo de cosas es muy fácil salir a decir
y la gente es violenta que son vándalos
y que hacen todo esto para alterar la
paz del país higuain
que ha hecho el gobierno frente a toda
la situación que se viene presentando
desde hace años atrás es que esta no es
la primera es que acá no estamos
generalizando a la institución como tal
es que no son solo dos policías si los
que han cometido este abuso han sido
muchos policías los que han abusado de
su autoridad y de su fuerza para
asesinar y para aprovecharse de las
personas entonces qué está haciendo la
institución como tal para
para mitigar este tipo de abuso y de
violencia por parte de la policía pero
acá estamos viviendo un problema en un
contexto del país muchísimo más grande
como tú lo decías al inicio a nivel
nacional se está viviendo nuevamente la
violencia de manera
intensa y cómo se está reacciona como
está reaccionando el gobierno nacional
frente a esto es que yo lo digo mira o
sea nosotros somos una familia y uno
mira y dice uy terrible lo que pasa hoy
asesinaron a una persona en la calle
murieron en actos vandálicos porque ese
es el el título entre comillas que se le
pone sí y uno mismo dice desde acá muy
terrible pero no pasa absolutamente nada
o sea del terrible no nos no no nos
salimos pero cuando le sucede a uno
cuando llega a cuando lo toca realmente
o sea jamás en la vida pensé que la
violencia de esta manera del país pueda
llegar a mi casa nunca me lo imaginé y
en esas circunstancias es tan horrorosas
entonces cuando ya uno le toca y cuando
llega acá entonces ahí es donde uno
siente el dolor realmente island de uno
siente la rabia y la impotencia al ver
que no se actúa de la manera que se
debería actuar o sea fue un vídeo que
fue demasiado claro desde el inicio y
sin embargo todo el tiempo se estuvo
diciendo que había sido un procedimiento
policial que se habían excedido pero
nunca se habla de la realidad como ágil
y todo lo porque en esta ocasión si una
prueba contundente que fue un vídeo como
evidencia de lo que lo hicieron entonces
ahí sí se empieza a actuar pero siempre
mientra es que pasa si eso no hubiese
ocurrido si ese vídeo no hubiese grabado
les pasaría lo mismo que ha pasado por
muchas víctimas del abuso policial
absolutamente nada en nuestro país
porque esa es la realidad aún hay muchos
casos anteriores
que están impunes no se ha actuado por
precisamente porque no no no ha habido
como algo una prueba que así pasó estos
y no siempre se ha querido justificar
justamente hay muchas denuncias en torno
al desempeño de la policía solamente la
alcaldía de bogotá ha denunciado 119
casos de abuso en las últimas semanas o
en la o en lo que lleva de gestión la
alcaldesa claudia lópez pero son
reiterados los las quejas y las
denuncias por parte de abusos en los
caic que son los centros de atención
ciudadana de atención rápida sobre todo
en sectores muy puntuales de la sociedad
colombiana la comunidad lgtb y las
mujeres los jóvenes muchos de ellos
denuncia que simplemente están en un
parque y que son increpados por la
policía por estar allí y son requisados
acusados y algunos han criticado este
tipo de actuar de la policía león
valencia el sistemático este
forma de actuar de la policía colombiana
que es señalada desde diferentes
sectores ya lo decía maría angélica solo
porque esta vez hubo un vídeo que
evidenció este abuso policial y este uso
de la fuerza ahora sí queda sobre la
mesa y en tela de juicio el accionar de
la policía pero no es nuevo
no no el nuevo es sin duda una actuación
en la que participa
una parte importante de la policía
nacional
no son manzanas podridas no son hechos
aislados
es una cosa estructural de la policía y
maría ángela al cual salud también la
margarita
pues no es una persona yo le doy la
primera entrevista que dio a la w radio
y me llamó mucho la atención porque yo
veía en un ser humano que no está en la
política que no tiene un partido una
decisión política pero que vio morir a
su esposo padre de sus dos hijos y
reaccionó con una sensatez ya enorme
incluso ella dijo no yo no acuso a todo
el mundo sino que quiero que se haga
justicia y eso es lo que sienten los
colombianos y las colombianas sienten la
gente común y corriente la indignación
no viene la incitación no viene de gente
que llama hacer desmanes la incitación
viene de ese hecho este un vídeo como
ese donde están matando a golpes a una
persona indefensa suscita ira eso es lo
que lo que genera todas estas protestas
como en eeuu se también en eeuu no hay
entonces las fuerzas terroristas que
dicen que hay acá
y ahí a la muerte de georg floyd el 25
de mayo suscitó eso mismo porque es muy
parecido es que la gente tiene esas
imágenes que vio en televisión y ahora
vio lo mismo acaba y lo vio
en las circunstancias dolorosas y por
eso yo creo que si la necesita digamos
una y margarida yo yo entiendo que la
oposición al gobierno de actual le saque
partido también a una realidad y ya es a
estos atropellos para criticar al
gobierno pero a mí me parece me parece
que yo no sé si margarita tiene hijos si
margarita tiene esposo si le matan el
esposo así si le matan a un hijo así
como reaccionaría margarita o sea que
diría a mí me parece una cosa
impresionante que por un medio logía
política el urbanismo un aura una
ideología
uno se niegue como ser humano como
piensa que es una gente bárbara que
incita la que produce todo esto es que
lo que produce es ese hecho y lo que
produce más indignación es que entonces
el gobierno colombiano primero regulará
los dos policías y segundo el propio
presidente se va es a solidarizarse con
la policía el propio presidente lo
invitan a una reunión con las víctimas
con esas víctimas con las familiares de
14 familias entre 14 personas asesinadas
y de más de 100 personas heridas y el
tipo no va y luego se van a
solidarizarse y se pone un casco de
policía oiga
yo creo que la sociedad colombiana me
parece a mí al más que ha reaccionado
más tranquilamente yo pensaría unas
cosas tan indolentes como esas que lo
que está sucediendo de hoy esas bolsas
de margarita debían debían suscitar más
una reacción de la sociedad colombiana
más fuerte sino precisamente eso le
quiero preguntar si no le parece usted
por favor se apuntar porque tengo que
darle paso a las otras dos invitadas
también si no le parece usted que la
cola a los colombianos a la sociedad de
este país le falta presionar más si
quiere cambios si quiere que no haya más
impunidad porque la sociedad colombiana
es completamente pasiva hay un rechazo a
la protesta se sataniza la protesta da
vergüenza salir a protestar porque eso
es de clases bajas o de izquierdista la
gente de las clases altas de bogotá
medellín o de cali no sale a
manifestarse en la calle a exigir que no
haya impunidad entonces la sociedad
colombiana está fallando ahí también
para exigir que esto cambie
la sociedad colombiana se manifestó muy
fuertemente
santiago en el 21 de noviembre del año
pasado y se salió a las calles como
nunca porque la sociedad como tú dices
es es muy retraída y retraída porque la
sociedad colombiana no es una sociedad
generalmente inconforme generalmente
crítica es más bien pasiva pero también
por la violencia porque le tienen miedo
a que cuando sale a protestar la matan y
uno entiende el ser humano pues su
principal valor su principal angustia es
la vida y entonces por eso no la ganaban
por qué ocurren estas cosas del estado
pero de verdad que la sociedad está
despertando y que las personas que no
sólo abusan como los policías sino que
tienen la complicidad personas como
margarita como su partido político pues
no les va a ir bien en los próximos años
en la política colombiana porque ya es
mucho descaro es
margarita su opinión al respecto allí en
la ciudad de rionegro en antioquia y
aprovechó y le pregunto cree usted que
ahora con toda esta coyuntura sería
necesaria una reforma en la policía
colombiana
bueno voy a empezar entonces por el tema
de la revertido sea puntual porque me
quedan pocos minutos de programa esto se
va muy rápido
pero que todo entiendo maría angélica me
parece respetuoso que se utilice a ella
oa javier como el florero de llorente
para promover la violencia para promover
una cantidad de cosas que no no esto no
son no vienen al caso lo primero es que
me solidarizo con variante del ica una
vez más y le digo que la entiendo porque
yo he sido víctima de la violencia mi
familia ha sido víctima de la violencia
y mi familia ha sido víctima de la bomba
bomba que pusieron los terroristas de
las farc en el nogal ha sido víctima de
muchos hechos lamentables por eso
entiendo y me solidarizo con maría
angélica y sé lo que es la violencia en
colombia
me llama la atención como un gestor de
paz que hace poco estaba diciendo que
había que perdonar y que la impunidad
tenía que romper cuando las
negociaciones o el falso acuerdo con las
farc ahora está hablando de rabia y
ahora está hablando de indicaciones a
sublevarse a salir a las calles tampoco
es verdad que sean las protestas algo
satanizado o algo para las clases altas
de hecho las protestas y pacíficas
han habido desde mi partido políticos
muchas en colombia de hecho se ha
pronunciado el pueblo colombiano también
se pronunció por ejemplo en el
plebiscito cuando dijo no a la impunidad
y seguimos siendo coherentes nosotros no
cambiamos de un día para otro pero no
quiero utilizar esta situación dolorosa
de maría angélica para este tipo de
cosas los policías el el ministro de
defensa han salido a pedir perdón
también se ha hablado de que es
importante una reforma que permita
delimitar adecuadamente las funciones
del ejército de la policía y es
gravísima la situación
en la que ha caído bogotá incluso la
máquina mayor causa de este caos que
bogotá hoy más que bogotá parece ciudad
gótica y es la falta de liderazgo de la
señora alcaldesa la falta de
conocimiento de la falta capacidad para
manejar este tipo de situaciones y ese
empeño en que siempre están pensando en
un fin todo es un instrumento para
llegar a un fin que tienen pre
construidos unos señores las víctimas no
puede ser un instrumento que pueden
utilizar a su amaño a las víctimas hay
que respetarlas y no se pueden
instrumentalizar y la protesta social la
protesta pacífica bienvenida por eso
claro hay que invitar a las calles a que
la gente se exprese
pero hay que saber hay que darles a
conocer los protocolos porque tampoco es
cierto que podamos permitir que se
destruya sus vidas que sedes ya las
ciudades que se agregan la fuerza
pública sino que todo debe ser con un
orden en el uribismo lo hemos hecho
música y lo más ante el pueblo tiene que
ser escuchado el pueblo no puede
permitir que pase lo que pasó con el
plebiscito cuando el señor juan manuel
santo será el presidente que desconoció
el pronunciamiento del constituyente
primario
como pregunta la pregunta que ahora
decide después de los hechos de estas
semanas en bogotá con este grado de
violencia y la acción de la policía los
colombianos van a querer salir a las
calles a manifestarse maría angélica le
hago una pregunta me quedan cinco
minutos de programa van a ustedes y su
familia han pensado de pronto en tomar
alguna acción legal contra el estado
colombiano por este tipo de situaciones
que se presentaron por la muerte de su
ex marido
que viene para ustedes en el futuro
mira en este momento y para hacer un
poco de claridad yo no me siento para
hacer un poco de claridad de la señora
mónica yo no me siento utilizada yo no
me siento utilizada porque siempre hemos
salido a hablar en voz propia y yo he
salido a hablar por javier
así que no participó en ningún partido
político no me interesa fuimos claros
desde el inicio diciendo que
rechazamos todo acto de violencia que se
hiciera el nombre de javier porque pues
no nos interesa nosotros lo que estamos
buscando en este momento de justicia y
claro que se viene un proceso nosotros
de hecho ya empezamos que pues
obviamente con todo el proceso de javier
y lo que queremos es que se haga
justicia con lo que pasó con él con las
personas que lo asesinaron que paguen
que se vayan a la cárcel o obviamente
que paguen la máxima condena porque
creemos que esa es la manera obviamente
hacer justicia y también de empezar un
poco a librar al país de aquellas
personas que andan sueltas asesinando sí
independientemente de donde si
corresponden a alguna institución o no
lo que queremos es que se empiecen a
hacer un poco más duras las penas y que
la justicia se empiece a poner de verdad
en rigor sí porque el mensaje que
pareciera uno que está mandando la misma
policía a su institución es que ellos
pueden hacer lo que quieran y no pasa
absolutamente nada es como si ellos
mismos se estuvieran riendo
de la institución ni siquiera la
ciudadanía entonces en eso yo sí
quisiera claro que exigimos y exigimos
justicia exigimos que no se puede quedar
la muerte de javier así sentimos también
que ha sido demasiado lento como se
decía anteriormente hasta hoy se
emitieron órdenes de captura
efectivamente no se sabe nada de lo que
pasó con los policías si están o no
están cuando debieron haber sido un
soldados pero sí estudiados desde el día
que sale el vídeo y mientras hacían todo
el proceso de investigación pero hoy no
sabemos qué pasó me quedan dos minutos
de programa lleguemos ya por favor a las
conclusiones león que va a suceder en
colombia en los próximos las próximas
semanas con este nuevo componente en esa
bolsa de indignación y de malestar
social que hay entre los jóvenes y entre
la sociedad colombiana sumado a la
coyuntura de la pandemia que tampoco
ayuda a estabilizar las cosas 20
segundos
pues mi gran preocupación mi gran dolor
mi gran angustia es que después de la
pandemia o en medio de la pandemia la
gente va a salir a protestar a las
calles
ala pacíficamente ojalá pacíficamente y
si no se envía un mensaje muy fuerte una
masa crítica de la sociedad y de la
comunidad internacional
para que los policías no actúen de la
misma manera que actuaron en esta
oportunidad para general porque están
sobre esta sociedad seguramente a
protestar y si la van a recibir así lo
que haber es una tragedia de dimensiones
colosales en colombia se elevan el
gobierno del presidente duque no para
esto si el uribismo no para esto va a
haber un desangre enorme yo le empleaba
la margarita en particular que ha sumado
otra exposición para pagar esto le van
lo corto porque tengo que cerrar el
programa margarita rápidamente su
conclusión
primero las personas pasan las
instituciones que la policía nacional
necesita una reforma delimitación de
funciones entre la policía y el ejército
y eso estaremos promoviendo desde el
congreso de la república y segundo
necesitamos justicia no hay paz con
impunidad necesitamos justicia y no hay
víctimas de primera y de segunda
justicia para todas las víctimas diez
segundos mar angélica rápidamente su
conclusión
mi conclusión o mi llamado sobre todo al
gobierno nacional como lo dije
anteriormente a que se solidarice con la
familia con las familias de las víctimas
a qué
realmente ya ponga una posición clara
porque no es clara la posición del
gobierno nacional tiene bastante
confusión ya que haga justicia a que
exija justicia ya que la lleve a cabo
margarita maría angélica y león' muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en el debate de france 24 de
ustedes gracias por la sintonía siga con
nuestra programación
[Música]